des espaces d'apprentissage et de jeu
pour pouvoir se détendre et rire
après avoir connu le pire c'est ce que
des organisations humanitaires comme
l'unicef mettent en place un peu partout
dans les camps de réfugiés rohingyas
nour callas 9 ans explique que sa mère a
été tué par l'armée birmane pas ça ne va
pas elle se tourne vers sa meilleure
amie où on prend soin l'une de l'autre
dit elle
sinon les enfants peuvent aussi parler à
des psychologues
les intervenants restent attentifs au
moindre signe de détresse quand il ya un
groupe de jeu et qu'un enfant reste
volontairement dehors du groupe où les
enfants sont aussi encouragés à dessiner
prendre soin de l'esprit mais aussi des
corps ainsi quand on manque encore de
tous aux installations sanitaires refuge
adéquat nourriture
plusieurs ong parlent d'un risque de
malnutrition aiguë bon nombre d'enfants
ne mangent est déjà pas à leur faim
avant de prendre le chemin prouvant de
l'exode et l'arrivée de nouveaux
réfugiés continuer à bousculer
l'organisation de l'aide c'est
l'importance de l'afflux sur la durée du
temps qui crée des réels problèmes de
survie en tenant compte 6 du terrain
quand même avec les collines et autres
qui rend toutes les actions un petit peu
d'eau et d'assainissement extrêmement
complexe la densité populationnelle est
très importante et donc on a un milieu
très fertile pour toute sorte d'épidémie
vu que les personnes vivent ensemble
dans un espace extrêmement réduit les
efforts de vaccination auprès des rues
n'ya qui n'ont pratiquement jamais été
vacciné vise notamment la rougeole
il ya déjà des centaines de cas c'est la
course contre la montre avant la saison
des pluies pour rendre lycans plus à lui
et dans ce chaos
cette école sert de point d'ancrage
selon ce professeur
[Musique]
il faut que les enfants comprennent
qu'ils doivent garder la foi même s'ils
ont dû tout quitter au myanmar dit il
n'aura tard douze ans retient surtout
qu'elle a dû fuir pour sauver sa peau en
nageant que son idole en apprend dans
les rangs notre héros du chili ces
arbres que vous voyez derrière moi c'est
là où se situe le no man's land une
étroite bande de terre qui est entourée
d'eau et c'est l'endroit où des dizaines
de milliers d'enfants et d'adultes
rohingya ont dû attendre parfois jusqu'à
deux ou trois jours avant de franchir un
dernier cours d'eau pour arriver ici en
sol bangladesh au sol des vestiges d'une
traversée houleuse parfois meurtrières
et dans les têtes des souvenirs
terribles paris il a 15 ans a perdu l'un
de ses frères
il a aussi perdu de vue plusieurs
membres de sa famille dans cette immense
camp de réfugiés
il n'en revient pas d'avoir à vivre ici
n'a rien à voir avec une belle maison
mais elle a été incendié pour occuper
les adolescents il n'y a pas d'école
comme pour les frites y est peu
d'encadrement dans les temps
[Musique]
des organisations comme l'unicef craint
que le désoeuvrement ne rangs des jeunes
vulnérables aux mariages forcés à la
prostitution à la criminalité
farid lui rêvait de devenir professeur
aujourd'hui il dit qu'il ne se voit plus
d'avenir ici et libéraux radio canada on
allie camps de réfugiés rohingyas au
bangladesh